المنصات تتفاعل مع معجزه خروج احياء من
تحت الانقاض بعد 200 ساعه من الزلزال وحرب
المناطيد اجدد فصول الصراع الصيني
الامريكي والهيئه الاتهاميه في لبنان تمنع
محاكمه فادي الهاشم بتهمه القتل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تجاوزت حصيله قتلى زلزال سوريا وتركيا 37
الف قتيل غير مئات الالاف من الجرحى
وملايين المتضررين ومئات الاف البيوت اللي
تدمرت واللي مهدده بالانهيار وعلى الرغم
من مرور اكثر من اسبوع على حدوثه لا زالت
الهزات الارتداديه مستمره والزلازل بتضرب
المنطقه بين حين واخر ورغم انه هذا
الزلزال تارك في قلوبنا ونفسنا اثر لا
يمكن للمحي يعني بيوم وليله ومثل ما حفر
كمان حتى بذاكرتنا ماسي وقصص مؤلمه لسه في
لحظات حقيقه يعني معرفه اوصفها الا ان
بانه يعني فعليا معجزه ولسه في نجاسه
بتطلع من تحت الانقاض عايشه حتى بعد مرور
اكثر من 200 ساعه على الزلزال
[موسيقى]
ثواني
[تصفيق]
ومن بين فيديوهات لحظات الانقاذ في فيديو
خطف القلوب وهو للحظه الاولى لاخراج طفله
سوريه من تحت الانقاض واللي اول ما جات
عينها في عيون منقذيها هذا اللي قالته
[موسيقى]
في فيديو اخر وكمان للطفل سوري ومتداول
بشكل واسع الساعات الماضيه او حقيقه من
اكثر المقاطع المؤثره وبيوثق لحظه شمل لم
شمل طفله سوريه تم انقاذها بوالدها اللي
نجح هو كمان وما بيجي غيرهم الاثنين من
العالم
[موسيقى]
والله
[تصفيق]
يا عسل
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد الصراع الصيني الامريكي
عنوان مو غريب ولا جديد ولكن يبدو انه
بنشهد حلقه جديده من حلقاته وفصل جديد من
فصول المواجهه الصينيه الامريكيه واحدث
المواجهات هذه نقدر نسميها حرب المناطيط
القصه بدات قبل اسابيع وقت تمرضات باسم
الولايات المتحده وشكوا فيه واتهموا الصين
انها هي اللي ارسلته للتجسس وقامت بعدين
امريكا واسقطته بصاروخ وطلعت الصين
واستنكرت اللي صار وقالت ردت الفعل اللي
عملتها امريكا مبالغ فيها وانه المنطاد
هذا انحرف عن مساره وان هو اصلا مخصص
للارصاد الجويه فقط الموضوع احتد لمن
الايام الماضيه امريكا اعلنت عن اسقاط
ثلاثه اجسام طائره مجهوله جديده واحده فوق
الاسكا ثاني بوب كندا والثالث على الحدود
الامريكيه الكنديه وباحجام واشكال مختلفه
فالاول كان بحجم سياره صغيره والثاني كان
اسطواني اما الثالث فكان بوصول بس المتصله
وطبعا اصابع الاتهام اتوجهت الصين اللي
عندها اسطول من المناصير وطلع المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون
كيربي وقال انه تم اسقاط الاجسام الطائره
المجهوله حفاظا على امن الولايات المتحده
من التجسس وما بيستبعدوا نصين ارسلتها
لغرض المراقبه الصين من جانبها في تماما
انه اصلا بتتجسس على امريكا وبتاكد انه
المنطاد الاول او حتى الثلاثه اجسام
الجديده ما لها علاقه فيهم وانها اصلا في
سنه 2022
رصدت الصين في سمائها عشره مناطيد امريكيه
وتصرفت معاها المهنيه ومسؤوليه
امريكا اللي اصلا قالت انه من قبل الحادثه
المنطاد هذه في مناطيت كثيره صينيه لقطوها
باجوائهم وخاصه في حكم ترامب كلام الصين
عن عشره مناطيد امريكيه باجوائها
تدخل في القصه وطلع الامين العام للحلف
وقال انه اللي بيصير في الولايات المتحده
بخصوص المناطيس الصينيه هو جزء من نمط
بتكون في الصين وروسيا لزياده انشطه
المراقبه على حلف شمال الاطلسي وبداوا
اصلا حبايب امريكي كمان يتجمعوا حولها ضد
الصين كندا من الاول ماخذه امريكا وتم
اسقاط اجسام فيها اصلا اليابان من ساعات
طلعت تكلمت قالت انه هي كمان رصد من 2019
ثلاثه مناطيد صينيه في اجوائها الصين
مسكتت ابدا وطلع المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه وقال انه المنطاد الاول الصيني
دخل المجال الجوي الامريكي عن طريق الخطا
اما الباقيين فما بيعرفوا عنهم اي شيء
وقال لما نتعلق الامر بمراقبه البلدان
الاخرى ومراقبتها فالولايات المتحده هي
امبراطوريه المراقبه
نحب هذه تحتاج نقاش عشان نفهمها فمعنا من
القاهره دكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
الاستراتيجيه اهلا فيك معنا الدكتور ايش
رايك في هذه الحرب هل نقدر فعلا نقول انه
في حرب بين امريكا والصين وانه المناطين
هي جالس السلاح فيها
يعني بالفعل يعني يمكن الاطلاق يعني او
وصف هذه ما يحدث منها هذه ظاهره بالفعل
باننا اذا يعني حرب مناطيد يعني العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه اصبحت يعني تحتمل
الكثير من التوصيفات يعني كما نعلم يعني
في منتصف عام 2018 كان هناك حديث عن الحرب
التجاريه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني تاريخ العلاقات مليء بهذا
النوع من المفاهيم واعتقد ان حاله التوتر
او التدهور الذي طال العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه خلال السنوات الاخيره والمتوقع ان
يشهد مزيد من التدهور خلال الفتره المقبله
اعتقد انه يفتح المجال الامام يعني مثل
هذا النوع من المفاهيم بالاضافه الى ذلك
فان على ما يبدو ان المناطيد يعني كان يتم
استخدامها منذ فتره ربما ما حدث فقط هو ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قررت ان
تتعامل الان بطريقه او بالاداء العسكريه
ضد هذه المناطيل وهذا السؤال مطروح داخل
الكونجرس الامريكي يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتحدث عن ان كان هناك مناطيد او
ان يعني البناطيد الصينيه يعني كانت معتاد
عليها او جرى استخدامها لفتره او منذ فتره
طويله والصين نفسها تتحدث عن ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني كان هناك مناطير
تدخل الاجواء الصينيه ولكن لم لم يتم
التعامل معها او وفقا للتعبير الصيني كان
يتم التعامل يعني
دكتور محمد انه التصرف والرد على هذه
المناطيل واسقاطها تصعيد من الولايات
المتحده
هو هو تصعيد واعتقد انه مفهوم يعني مفهوم
في سياق التدهور القائم في العلاقات بين
الجانبين هناك رسائل كل طرف يسعى الى
توصيل رسائل شديده الوضوح للطرف الاخر
فيما يتعلق بسقف او يعني
سقف توقعات الطرف الاخر بالنسبه لسلوكها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اراد التوصيل
رساله واضحه بانها بدات تكون على استعداد
اكبر لاستخدام القوه العسكريه في سياق
العلاقات القائمه بين الجانبين صحيح انه
يتم استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد
جسم صيني ويتم داخل الاجواء الامريكيه وهو
حق يعني للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
لم يكن يتم استخدام هذه الاداه او الاداه
العسكريه قبل ذلك بل لم يكن يتم الكشف
عنها لكن الان اصبحت الامور تتم بدرجه
اكبر من العلني العل درجه اكبر من الوضوح
وتوظيف رسائل او توظيف ادوات جديده في
العلاقات او في الصراع بين الجانبين احنا
خلينا بس نذكر ان الصين جلسه بتنفي هذا
الكلام لكن اذا افتراضا انه مشينا مع
الروايه الامريكيه انه ارسال من الطيز
لامريكا لكندا لليابان ليش ارسال المناطيل
هذه كلها طب ما في وسائل مختلفه اخرى
للتجسس يعني
المناطير لها خصوصيه بالمقارنه بيئه
الاقمار الاصطناعيه البناطيد ارخص من حيث
التكلفه
بالمقارنه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه ايضا فيما
يتعلق
بامكانيات تحليقها على مستويات اقل من
الاقمار الصناعيه ربما هذا يكون له يعني
تاثير فيما يتعلق بجوده الصور او غيرها
لكن في المجمل الميزه الاساسيه التي تميز
المناطيد انها اقل من حيث التكلفه
بالمقارنه بالادوات الاخرى هذا يعني ما
يفسر الاعتماد على اليه المناطيد رغم جميع
الاطراف تعتمد على الاليات الاخرى جميع
الاطراف تعتمد على توظيف يعني الادوات
الاخرى في التجسس لكن على ما يبدو ان
المناطيد مازال تحتفظ ببعض الميزات التي
تفسر اعتماد جميع الاطراف على هذه الظاهره
او هذه الاداه طيب اذا رحنا للروايه
الصينيه اللي هي بتنفي وجلسه حتى بتقول
انه يعني معليش انتو يا الولايات المتحده
يعني انتم اصلا امبراطوريين او انتو
امبراطوريه
المراقبه يعني فلا تقعدوا ترموا التهم
علينا هل بتصدق هذا الموضوع منهم او نفيهم
يعني اعتقد الروايه الصينيه يعني او سرديه
الصينيه ضعيفه منذ ان بدات يعني كان هناك
يعني في البدايه كان هناك حتى تردد في او
يعني تغير في التبرير الصيني كان هناك نفي
ثم انك كان هناك يعني تبرير ثم التاكيد
على انهم حاجه الان ورد الدكتور محمد معلش
بس ورد عاجل الان من البيت الابيض بيقول
لا مؤشرات على انه الاجسام التي تم
اسقاطها مرتبطه ببرنامج تجسس صيني كانه
تراجع في الموقف الامريكي
يعني اعتقد هذا ينصرف على الاجسام الثلاثه
الاخيره التي تم يعني ضربها او تدميرها
لكن اعتقد فيما يتعلق بالمنطاد الصيني
الصين نفسها لم ترفض او لم تنفي انقاذ هو
منطاد صيني فقط الاختلاف بين الجانبين
يتعلق بما اذا كان مهمتهم مهمه مدنيه او
تتعلق يعني بانشطه تتعلق
المهام بحثيه ام انه منطاد لاهداف عسكريه
لكن الصين لم تنفي ان هذا المنطاد هو مضاد
صيني طب بالعوده لحديثك اللي كنت تتحدث
فيه عن
التبرير الصيني او رفض الصيني لهذه
الاتهامات تقدر تكمل فكرتك لو سمحت
نعم يعني اعتقد ان الروايه الصينيه كما
اشرت قبل ذلك كانت ضعيفه منذ البدايه
واعتقد ان هذا الامر فقط يتعلق بالتغير
الذي حدث فيما يتعلق بمواقف الاطراف او
طريقه تعامل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مع الظاهره لكن الواضح ان اليه المناطيد
كان يتم استخدامها بكثافه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن جانب الصين ايضا ما
يحدث او الجديد ايضا ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تستخدم هذه الظاهره الجديده
لخلق مناء راي عام عالمي ضد هذه الظاهره
وضد الصين يعني نلاحظ ان اليابان بدات كرد
فعل او بدات يعني تتحدث عن ان هناك اجسام
تم رصدها منذ سنوات في عام 2019 او في
السنوات الاخيره
كندا تحدثت عن نفس الامر دخول حلف الناتو
فالواضح او التطور الجديد في هذا الاطار
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد توظيف
هذه الظاهره لخلق للتاكيد على
خلق مناخ او اطار او يعني ري عامي ضد
الصين الصين طيب احنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا دكتور محمد فايز فرحات
مدير مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
وغير الصراع بين امريكا والصين في صراع من
نوع ثاني انفتح صراع بين المؤمنين بوجود
كائنات فضائيه واللي مو مصدقين الكلام
امريكي لما تكلمت عن الاجسام الجديده اللي
اسقطتها سمتها
في العربي اجسام طائره مجهوله هذا المسمى
من عقود مرتبط بالحديث عن كائنات فضائيه
وهبوطه على الارض وفي معسكرات كبيره في
العالم مؤمنه انه هذا الشيء صار اكثر من
مره وانه في كائنات فضائيه نزلت قبل كده
على الارض فلما امريكا طلعت تكلمت عن
ثلاثه اجسام جديده طلع هذا المعسكر وقلك
هذا الظهور جديد للكائنات الفضائيه
واستندوا في كلامهم على تصريح لجنرال
امريكي ما استبعد هذا الاحتمال ابدا
فيديو
طبعا سمعنا الصحفيين بيضحكوا في القاعه
وكتار يمكن يضحكوا بالموضوع لكن حقيقي هو
ذرى الموضوع جدا حقيقي جدا والصراع هذا
حقيقي وبامانه التصريح ما فرق كثير
والصراع لسه قائم واعتقد راح يفضل قائم
لسنوات طويله بين المؤمنين قطعا بانه في
كائنات فضائيه وبين المشككين يعني يمكن
اسهل طريق الحسم الموضوع هذا وحسم الجدل
لو موجودين يا جماعه ينزلوا ويظهروا
ويخلصون عادي ويشيلونا معاهم خلاص بعد
كورونا تبلد احساسي انا
[موسيقى]
الستار اليوم على جريمه شغله الراي العام
من ثلاث سنوات او اكثر شوي المحكمه اليوم
اصدرت قرارها بمنع محاكمه الدكتور فادي
الهاشم زوج الفنانه نانسي عجرم بتهمه
القتل لمحمد موسى الشاب السوري اللي بحسبه
تحقيقات اقتحم منزل الثنائي بدافع السرقه
واطلق عليه فادي ثمانيه
رصاصه القصه صارت في 5 يناير 2019 وبدات
الروايات من وقتها الروايه الاولى
والرسميه للان محمد الموسى كان داخل يسرق
ولما انتبه عليه الدكتور فادي اطلق عليه
النار ومن اول يوم فادي مصر انه الموضوع
كان دفاع عن النفس لكن تحليلات للمشهد
والفيديوهات والصور وتفاصيل كثيره بدات
تطلع وتقول كلام ثاني فسمعنا كلام عن
علاقه بتربط بين الاثنين من قبل وتساؤلات
انه ليه 18 طلقه وعلامات استفهام عن مكان
وجود الجثه وانه ما تتفق مع روايه الدفاع
عن النفس وكلام ثاني كثير ولكن الهيئه
اليوم اصدرت قرارها سكتت الكلام خلاص
واصدرت حكم القانون ومنعت محاكمه فادي
الهاشم وقالت انه في مبرر للفعل اخرجوا من
نطاق التجريم وانه المدعى عليه كان في
حاله دفاع عن النفس خاصه مع الوضع النفسي
اللي كان فيه وجود القتيل في مكان قريب
جدا من غرفه بناته فضلا عن لبسه اسود في
اسود والظلام اللي كان في الغرفه وقتها
الاعلام كله جالس بيتناول الموضوع على انه
براءه دكتور فادي الهاشم لكن الموضوع
قانونيا مباراه من القضاء منع المحاكمه
اصلا خليني اشرح لكم بس الموضوع مثل ما
يعني نحن من محاميين ومختصين بالقانون في
لبنان الوثيقه المنتشره للحكم ومثل مو
شايفين ما فيها كلمه براءه لانه ببساطه
صادره عن الهيئه الاتهاميه اللي ما لها
صلاحيه انه تحكم بالبراءه هذا غير انه
قضيه ما وصلت اصلا لمحكمه الجنايات ليبدا
التقاضي فيها الهيئه الاتهاميه هذه اللي
المفروض توجه التهمه للمتهم ومن بعدها
تروح للقضيه محكمه الجنايات وبعد ما بحثت
في القضيه لقيت انه صحيح في جرم قتل وقع
لكن في مبرر بيخليه فعل مشروع ولا يستدعي
المحاكمه وبيمنعها وهذا اللي صار في هذه
القضيه مبرر الدكتور فادي كان الدفاع عن
النفس والهيئه الاتهاميه مبرر يستوجب منع
محاكمته من الاساس
زعيم كوريا الشماليه عنده ثلاثه اولاد
اسمائهم واي معلومات عنهم مو معروفه ولا
حتى كانوا شاف اي منهم في الاعلام الان في
اثنين محد عمره شافهم او يعرف عنهم الشيء
لكن من كم شهر ظهرت معالم المره الاولى
بنته اللي عمرها يقدر بنت تسعه وعشره
سنوات ومن وقتها في نوفمبر ظهرت معاه
اربعه مرات اخرها من كم يوم في عرض خلال
عرض عسكري كبير احتفالا بالذكرى الخامسه
والسبعين لتاسيس جيش البلاد الاعلام
الكوري الشمالي وصفها بابنه الزعيم
الفاضله والاعلام الغربي بيقول انها ابنه
المفضله وانه جالس بيجهزها تكون خليفه في
الحكم واللي زادت تكهنات عن اختيار كم
لابنتها انها تكون خلف لو هو اصدار عدد من
الطوابع البريديه الجديده خمسه منها بتحمل
صورتهم مع بعض
معروف عنه القرارات والاوامر الغريبه وفي
قرار جديد مختص في موضوع بنته هذا الشاغل
العالم فكم اصدقرار رئاسي بيمنع تسميه اي
بنت باسم بنته
ومو بس كده تخيلوا انه قرر كمان انه اي
احد مسمي بنته بهذا الاسم يتواصل فورا مع
الادارات الرسميه علشان تغير اسمها وبحسب
مصادر في القرار بيقول انه هذا اسم مخصص
لذوي اعلى درجات الكرامه فقط عموما يعني
لو وصلت الحكم حتكون رابع جيل من اسره كم
يحكم كوريا الشماليه والانثى كمان
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم ونعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله